hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast dtc genomic testing a
healthcare system perspective presented
by Amjad al-hussein personalized
medicine integration manager and Nova
Center for personalized health
I am Alexis Krause of lab routes and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
and type your question into the drop
down box that appears on the screen well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen
or use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
abjad al-hussein I will now turn the
presentation over to her
thank here it is such a pleasure to be
here today I'm excited to share with you
some of our learning on
direct-to-consumer models for genomic
testing and how the Innova healthcare
system has used some of these approaches
to implement genomic offerings so our
objectives for today are to discuss some
of the challenges associated with
providing direct-to-consumer genetic
test while being part of the healthcare
system
and discussing what tactics that we have
experience using and how you might want
to consider using for your own
healthcare system and then finally
comparing some of the benefits and
disadvantages of using a direct consumer
model as opposed to a provider driven
model well start off with a background
on our system our history with genetic
testing and where we are today
Nova Health System is a large
not-for-profit health care system in
Northern Virginia we're right outside of
Washington DC we serve more than 2
million people each year and our
comprehensive network of 5 hospitals and
outpatient services that includes both
primary care and specialty care we see
thousands and thousands of patients our
outpatient centers each year and we have
a strong commitment to genomics and
personalized health where we have been a
global leader in implementing precision
medicine uses within our healthcare
system the state of the industry as we
know is forever changing and healthcare
systems like ourselves are constantly
finding innovative ways to adjust to
these challenges precision medicine is a
priority at Inova and we work closely
with our physicians to better target our
strategies to serve the population
that come to us for their care we're
also very active and keeping that with
what consumers are looking for and as we
know on generations go and he won't come
to have different expectations or how
they receive their health care so that's
an important part of learning from
direct to consumer models both within
the healthcare system and models from
other industries we're constantly
learning and adapting all while keeping
our patients in this Center and then
being our main focus because they are
the reason why we do what we do another
important piece to all of this is
staying well connected and engaged with
our physician leaders through champion
many of our efforts and help us get
these on innovative genomic testing
offering to the bedside and without them
we wouldn't be able to create a
personalized approach to healthcare and
we're really going from now this
traditional model of here's a patient
that comes to us is already sick and its
really taking care of healthy people in
the community and keeping them well so
it's personalized health not just
decision medicine for individuals who
are already sick and in this world that
we know is already very complicated hot
areas in omics and many of you may have
seen this so I've identified by dr. Eric
green from the National Human Genome
Research Institute there's a lot of
areas within genomics that different
healthcare systems are currently playing
in at Inova we're very active in all of
these areas so from cancer genomics to
pharmacogenomics genetic disease
Diagnostics newborn genomic analysis and
clinical genomics today our focus will
be on pharmacogenomics that we are
really repeating this area in our region
and I'd like to share some of the
challenges
we've experienced integrating
pharmacogenomic testing within our
system but more importantly share with
you some of the tactics that while we've
been successful in integrating those to
swim just a little bit of history our
ANOVA translational medicine institute
first launched in 2011 and we kicked off
with the first study with premature
births where we looked at rare genetic
disorders and from there really started
pushing our precision medicine effort
2014 was when our anova genomics
laboratory was initially launched though
it is a CLIA certified and now proudly a
cap accredited lab all of our genomic
tests are done in-house and then in 2016
was when we launched our first Medi map
pharmacogenomic tests for newborns and
I'll be jumping in more deeply into that
program but that really put us on the
map for thinking about how pbx testing
can be integrated into systems in an
innovative way that isn't traditional
yes pushing the boundaries with how PGX
testing can be offered but it really
opened up a lot of doors with educating
physicians and not only our clinical
community but patients that we serve
so the 2017 was when we launched Metis
map services more directly to the public
and we open our very math clinic and
then later that year we want a few pilot
studies within our primary care offices
I've started to build some value based
systems to really demonstrate to
physicians how this type of testing can
positively impact the care that they can
deliver to their patients this year
there's definitely a lot going on but
one of the things that I wanted to
highlight the Innova is working on
offering Medi map pharmacogenomic
testing to employees as part of our
employee wellness program and although
that's not
the focus of our presentation on that's
definitely one of our greatest successes
that we're very proud of this year all
right so learning from direct consumer
models and I just want to know that this
presentation is really about looking at
those models and approaches to
implementing pharmacogenomic testing now
at Inova it isn't a pure direct consumer
model because all of our tests are
clinical tests that are ordered by
providers but there are a lot of
learnings that we can take from
healthcare drift consumer models as well
as models from different industries so
this is our fabulous team that Innova
genomics laboratory which I mentioned is
CLIA certified and kapha accredited it
is part of our ANOVA translational
medicine Institute which fits under the
ANOVA Center for personalized health so
jumping ahead ANOVA genomics laboratory
offers a large variety of genomic test
pharmacogenomics has been one of our
biggest focuses and the focus of today's
segmentation I take a step back and talk
about pharmacogenomics what is it this
is the way that I like to break it down
because I'm finding that it's a good way
to introduce it to both clinicians and
the general public the pharmacogenomics
is essentially pharmacology which is the
study of medications and genomics the
study of how people's genetic
information can influence their health
so pharmacogenomics is the study of how
people's genes affect the response to
medications it's often abbreviated into
PGX
so when you hear me say PGX that means
from the code genomics and people often
mistake in this type of genetic testing
for whole genome sequencing so the type
of tests that may tell you have what
disease risk you may have or other
popular testing examples such as
ancestry this
none of that so the beauty is of
pharmacogenomic testing is that it's
really focusing on how people respond to
medications and a relatively low-risk
type of testing that is not as
intimidating to both patients and
physicians
more than four billion medications are
ordered and dispensed and one year
most of those happen to be
antidepressant painkillers and lipids
and if you take a look at the United
States and people using prescription
medication more than 48 percent have one
or more prescriptions
21.2% have three or more and then 11.9%
have five or more so you can imagine the
type of adverse reaction they may deal
with whether it's one or more
medications that they're on and it can
just get more complex with the different
medication interactions that they may
experience
the easy thing is lot of people and
you'll see here with the percentages
under the different on drug categories
you know people that are responding
effectively to the medications that
they're receiving so just would
antidepressants 38 percent are finding
their medication to be ineffective
imagine the potential is we can offer a
genetic test where people and know how
they may respond to these medications
before they ever take them and instead
of taking the trial and error process
which is most traditional and physicians
will tell you you know yes there are a
lot of factors that impact the way we
respond to medications it's not very
black and white and so pharmacogenomics
testing can be another tool in a
physician's toolkit that they can use to
help better gauge which medication to
start with and hopefully reduce the
likelihood that someone won't respond to
a medication effectively I don't know of
a pharmacogenomics is a perfect example
of how we're changing the future of
health we're challenging physicians to
think about genetic testing as a way to
become more preventative and use
pre-emptive testing to improve the
overall care of our patients as opposed
to waiting to get someone on a
medication and then going back to
pharmacogenomics testing and see why or
why not
this type of medication does not work
it's really a different way of providing
care and the way that we're doing that
is challenging the traditional models by
incorporating this type of testing and
bundle so making it part of routine care
we're almost becomes a standard within a
service during service line
we're also really engaging our
physicians and creating physician
champions who are leading the way with
our special programs and research pilots
that I haven't mentioned and most
importantly it's all about patient
empowerment
and educating people on how this sort of
information can give them better control
and we've got a different option that
hasn't been available in the past and
some of the speaks to the direct to
consumer models that are available and
really being open and transparent about
what options there are where this
information comes from and how they can
use it responsive weave and provide that
information to their providers
so Innova created Metis map which was
our first trademark commercial product
line at Inova Metis map is an umbrella
for all of our teachers test we have
baseline test condition specific tests
and single gene and pilot tests this
portfolio of tests was meant to get
physicians and our community options
based on what their needs are we didn't
think that single drug test was the way
to go again pushing that preventive
model giving people access to based on
tests that would help them have
information that can be useful for the
future although we're not talking about
whole genome sequencing in this
presentation I did want to mention that
ANOVA does have a my math product which
is a whole genome sequencing screening
test that's one of the first models for
integrating whole genome data into
clinical care all integrated within our
medical records and provide physicians
with antonova information that they can
use in everyday care access choice and
transparency all fundamental parts of
direct consumer models it was very
important to us to give both physicians
and patients all the information that
they need to make an informed decision
on what genomic test is best for them
these are two screenshots from our
website so every single Medi map test as
a druggist online that is really
accessible to anyone we also list the
number of genes are tested all the
medications that are included and the
prices one of the things that we were
you know feels very strongly about that
pricing should be transparent since
these are not covered by insurance so
all of our tests are panels and panels
are currently not covered by health
insurance so just another way that we're
demonstrating transparency I'd also like
to highlight the evidence
column on all of our gene and drug lists
now this is something that isn't
commonly seen with most labs that
provide pharmacogenomics testing the
whole correspond to either actionable or
informative findings that are helpful
for physicians so that they are better
informed on which recommendations come
from wrong evidence that can be used in
clinical care this is important because
a lot of tests out there don't provide
the fixation and some recommendations
may be weaker than others any of our
physicians love that we include this and
it has been one of the reasons why we
have been pretty successful in getting
them engaged and more comfortable with
you utilizing these types of tests our
reports started off very different from
what you're seeing on screen we now have
a nice color-coded report that follows
the traffic light system our goal was to
make it easy to understand the gener for
the general public and also for
physicians that don't have any
experience with genetic tests as long as
you know pharmacogenomics training isn't
part of most medical school curriculum
and so we wanted to give them the
resources to be able to now use the
recommendations easily but then also
have direct access to our genetic
counselors and geneticists at our labs
that provide that back-end support we
also work tirelessly to integrate
pharmacogenomic results into our
electronic medical record which is epic
currently have a universal of best
practice advisory essentially an alert
that is triggered when a provider
prescribes the particular medication so
let's say little Johnny gets this
pharmacogenomic test done at one of our
hospitals where we have a minimap baby
program pharmacogenomic testing is
provided
of our standard package of service the
newborns our family has the option to
take part in this program and the babies
results would go into our electronic
medical record so again let's say little
Johnny comes back to Nova in ten years
and is in the ER needs a medication the
ER physician prescribes medication that
happens to be on that panel the
electronic medical record will notify
the provider that pharmacogenomic
information is in the system and it will
directly link to those results this is
an incredibly important safety feature
that we've integrated and one of the
benefits of getting pharmacogenomics
testing that part from a healthcare
system that really has a high-level view
of the patient's clinical care how to
get a minimap test so like I mentioned
all of our tests are clinical tests and
are ordered by providers or physicians
now Nova physicians can choose to order
the tests themselves or refer a patient
directly to our MIDI map clinic which is
located at the genomics laboratory and
not a nova sufficient they don't have
access to our ordering systems can write
Medi map prescriptions now this is all
great but thinking about DTC models and
how we can make this accessible to the
general public we didn't want to rely on
each individual primary care physician
or specialist to order this and you know
through a lot of patient surveys we've
learned that there are physicians that
aren't comfortable ordering this type of
stuff so how can we make this accessible
any patient can call our lab directly
you can appointment at the clinic and
what would happen is they essentially
come in to see a genetic counselor go
over the medications that they're
currently on or you know if this is
something that they want to do
preemptively and again like Lee says no
preventive perspective the genetic
counselors would be there to explain how
this type of testing can be helpful and
important for the future and then we
have
our own physician who would order this
time
migration challenges so although right
now we do have a seamless process where
we accept patients we do a testing we
return the results all physicians are
very big part of all that process but it
wasn't an easy experiences along the way
in any health care system deaf
experience integrating the PGX testing
would stay the same so in the different
categories that I'll walk through and
give you some examples of what those
challenges are and immigration tactics
of how we overcame them at the system
level it was essential that we had the
support of our executive leadership as I
mentioned ANOVA is heavily investment in
precision medicine and at the very top
level there was a push to create
tangible examples of how precision
medicine is being used at the bedside
so that was an essential piece to our
success and really demonstrated the
commitment that our team had to making
this a success perforating PGX
testing as part of the standard package
of care and different service lines was
also another great way we were able to
weave in PGX
testing in areas that may or may not
have traditionally used PGX testing in
the past and making it a standard part
of care or the package of services that
we're providing really pushed our
physicians to get on board with venue
offering and learn how to utilize that
information in a way that can improve
the overall patient's experience
education so as you know the education
piece is always difficult no matter what
new intervention you're introducing
whether it's a new piece of technology a
new checklist that you're trying to
implement the challenges are
never-ending but one of the things we've
learned was pharmacogenomics testing is
the base blind need to be pretty similar
both with physicians and individuals now
of course with physicians at very doing
you had early adopters who were now
paying close attention to what's
happening in the field and some
especially in the behavioral health area
had some experience with
pharmacogenomics testing but then there
was a very large proportion who were not
very familiar with pharmacogenomic
testing and really needed a lot of forth
on the back end you know after they
receive their results and figuring out
what to do with them so it was critical
for us to go back to basics and create a
level setting resource for educational
materials that was available for
physicians and so we work closely with
our leaders to grow the service lines
lowly and we a lot of times visiting and
doing around with different positions to
better explain all the evidence that is
being used to create these tests as I
mentioned before there were some key
elements that help us better engage
physicians and improve the likelihood
that they would adopt some of these
having these tests be done in-house for
the big piece today engaging physician
leaders in the creation of the reports
was another critical piece we initially
started with this very very lengthy
report that was not color-coordinated
and getting their feedback to create
something that was more users assembly
was principal and then finally the
electronic medical record and
integration was a huge
shader' so even for physicians that were
previously ordering on pharmacogenomics
test from allied laboratories they were
more than happy to switch to our
internal testing option because they
wanted to take advantage of that patient
safety element that was a no-brainer for
individuals pharmacogenomics is a tongue
twister and so having a test umbrella
named Medi map has really helped us gain
traction and brand recognition in the
community selecting service lines that
have the great in the community was a
good way to start introducing PGX
testing to the community and then again
creating materials that would make cgx
testing easy to understand in a way
that's easily relatable to the general
consumer result interpretation so I've
mentioned creating the report was a big
success for us sharing the results is
still a challenge and with a lot of our
colleagues at different healthcare
system it seems to be a common challenge
right now all of our reports are sent to
patients by mail
now although our results are in the
electronic medical record they are not
accessible via my chart with which is a
patient portal and because the nature of
genetic testing and the laws that govern
that both federally and at the state
level as you can imagine the security
level required for those results are
much more difficult to navigate so
that's still a challenge that innova and
many other healthcare systems you'll
still deal with it as medication less
grown on when I say medication less I
mean the ones that do have a genetic
component to them it's important to be
able to reanalyze and provide patients
with the option to learn more about how
these new medications on
would impact the response some
integration so pre-emptive testing again
doing that education needed to create a
paradigm shift is essential to weaving
in this type of testing to the massive
EMR integration as I mentioned we have
been successful in ordering result
storage best practice advisory alerts
and system interoperability however
patient access continues to be a
challenge every didn't payment my
favorite so health insurance was you
know in a lot of fields they there's a
gap and they fall behind in a lot of
areas on the co genomics and genetic
testing is one of those now although
health insurance companies are somewhat
covering single drug pharmacogenomic
test panels are currently not covered
this is a challenge there's a lot of
patients who would really benefit from
this can simply not afford this type of
testing our Medi math test range from
195 to 395 our largest panel includes
145 medications and all of our tests are
out-of-pocket tests only we've been
working closely with vanish'd care to be
able to find ways in which we can
incorporate on PDX testing into health
plan and one of the successes is that
some insurance companies are willing to
let their members user SFA's in HSA
towards PGX testing which is a great
option Epic's payment is a challenge and
you know if you're thinking of it from a
dtc perspective and what consumers
expect from a service that they're
paying out of pocket for they expect
easy online payment digital receipt
receiving their results electronically
all of these things can be more
complicated when you're trying to
of them within an integrated health care
system it is very complex as many levels
and tiers of security so you can imagine
how setting up PayPal may not work very
seamlessly we are making progress in
this area and by the end of 2018 we
should have an online payment system
ego and compliance so when somebody asks
me what is the greatest piece of advice
you would give to the healthcare system
first starting out with PGX innovation
it was your legal department the best
friends you're really going to need to
rely on their expertise and work with
them closely to make sure that your
integration efforts are following all
federal and state regulations as well as
managed care regulations us being right
outside of the DC area we also deal with
unique challenges so within the legal
and compliance based position liability
has also been a concern give a quick
example so if a PBX test is done for an
individual early on in life and the
information is included in electronic
medical records a physician may or may
not be concerned with how that
information may make them liable for any
adverse reactions that a patient has in
the future
now Nova does have the best practice
advisory capability so in that sense we
do have that safety feature that
protects patients and alert physicians
as needed for physicians outside of
innova who do not have access to our
system have often raised this concern so
it's a lot of Education that needs to be
done and have them better understand
what they are and are not liable to and
further educating patients to know that
they're responsible for sharing their
results with all providers that they see
another interesting PACA know and as we
learn from dtc models and how we can
make PGX testings that are accessible to
the masses in a community marketing is
not the easiest thing when it comes to
genetic testing and it varies by state
not every state allows companies and
organizations to directly market genetic
tests to the residence so even if our
tests are
in a Korea and cap accredited laboratory
that doesn't give us clearance to
directly market to residents so again
without the support of our legal and
compliance department your department
can get in a lot of trouble for this
another area is testing for employees
with Gina and other laws testing for
employees is limited but luckily we were
able to find a way for ourselves to make
offering available to our internal
investors and as I mentioned we are
pushing forward with a special program
to offer Medi math as part of our anova
employee wellness program so more to
come on des
finally access to results now most of
our customers are shocked when we tell
them that we actually don't email the
results to them and that is a paper copy
this is a challenge that I believe most
healthcare systems are facing but as new
technologies come into place and we're
able to extend those access points it
will definitely improve that patient
experience and more importantly giving
physicians that appropriate access for
them to be able to get to the right
information at the right time so they
can accurately prescribe medication
just a quick list of integration ones I
know the past two PGX
innovation hasn't been easy the elements
that we have been able to achieve is
epic integration incorporating PDX
testing into standard packages of
services again working very closely with
service line leaders and creating custom
tests that they need in order to improve
their care delivery and then pilots that
demonstrate the impact on the standard
of care as I mentioned we work very
closely with our primary care offices to
engage those digits and physicians and
create pilot program where PGX testing
truly becomes part of the standard care
package my team at baby program um is
indeed a unique program that we have at
Inova and we continue to offer
pharmacogenomics testing to every
newborn deaths delivered at our system
this has been an incredible way to
introduce our physicians to
pharmacogenomic testing and although
babies may not use medications
immediately the potential of empowering
them with that with their families but
that information early on in life can be
a game-changer with how we think about
pharmacogenomics testing and how its of
pre-emptive solution to future adverse
reactions
such on our lessons learned and some
advice that I would give to any health
care system starting out with PGX
testing back to education basis almost
everyone is at the same level investing
in your educational framework and the
support staff that is there to provide
physicians with that support that they
need to interpret results and use that
information in their everyday practice
is critical from the consumer
perspective think about how you can make
the information not only easily
accessible but easy to understand and
getting out of our clinical bubble and
really engaging communications experts
to simplify the language so that it
truly is patient-centered consumer
centered and having all the information
easily available online that has been an
essential piece to our success
we've learned that consumers you know
once you take the time to explain what
PDX testing is the value it can have an
impact it can have on their lives they
want it and they want to use it we've
been blown away with the support that
we've received from our community to
parents that are ecstatic to have access
to testing like this that can help
they'll trip their children and the
physicians caring for their children
know which medications start with as
opposed to the whole trial and error
process of prescribing has been
overwhelming and I think it's important
to not let our traditional healthcare
pressures push us back from implementing
innovative genomic tests such as these
and bring it to the community people
will understand it they'll want it and
once they start using it I believe
physicians will catch up and we've seen
this within our organization and as you
are able to tell more stories on the
impact and show that both the clinical
and cost value menu will catch up and
your adopters will just pile on so one
thing that I do want to really emphasize
is although direct-to-consumer models
are relatively easy to execute from the
business perspective outside of the
healthcare system it may not be the best
approach for a more integrated
healthcare system that you know
hospitals and outpatient clinics however
adopting many of those principles with
the patient and consumer experience
front and center will definitely enhance
your chances of success reimbursement
will again forever
lag behind not wait until health
insurance companies are covering this to
start offering this to your patients I
think in this field if we don't start
using these innovative tests you will
never get to the point where we're able
to demonstrate that clinical validity
and cost-effectiveness that health
insurance companies are looking for
about making this type of testing
affordable and accessible to patients is
the most important so although it's not
going to be a cash cow it is definitely
in that category of high potential for
drastically improving the care that we
provide another thing is getting
together with a team of internal experts
one of the keys to our success was very
early on before we launched any
pharmacogenomic tests we brought
together a group of internal experts
that met on a regular basis and we
tackled every challenge as a team so
those really interdisciplinary we engage
the right champion that
the right time and we push the
boundaries and challenged every obstacle
you know every time you're highly secure
health care system Sylvio you absolutely
cannot you know so this test in this way
we challenge them and ask them to help
us come up with solutions again
to make this patient friendly offering
so in conclusion thank you all for
joining me I encourage you to visit our
website that's anova org slash Medi map
where we list all of our MIDI map
offerings and you're more than welcome
to reach out to me at any time if you
have any question
thank you I'm John for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is how was the meta
map baby program funded was excessive
successful in terms of participation and
what are the common concerns for pick
from parents
great question and I often get this
question when I bring up the baby
program so the minimap baby program dasa
recap for everyone is program that we
started in 2016 and every newborn that's
delivered at Inova has the option to
have a minimap baby test it covers seven
genes and 24 of medications and the
report is customized with both pediatric
and adult recommendations now it is
internally funded so as I mentioned
ANOVA is highly committed to
implementing precision medicine and the
baby program is just one example of how
we're doing that so there is no
additional cost to the family and it is
completely bundled into the package of
service for every baby delivered common
questions that we get from parents be
honest have to do with security what
will you do with my baby sample how long
will the sample stay in your lab what do
you do with that sample after you're
done collecting the DNA where did the
results go so we have a very good
authorization form that we've created
that has several opt-out questions so
parents are able to opt out if they
don't want their child the identified
information to be included in aggregate
data sets our use for you see model
quality control in the lab so I think
those all doubt questions make them very
comfortable overall after they're
educated with what the offering is so
are very open to this type of testing
many people are amazed with you know
what the technology can do and more than
80% of families are participating which
is huge when frozen we're happy to know
that we've tested more than 12
thousand babies since we first started
the program the reach and the impact
that we've had in the community has been
enormous and we're hoping that as more
people learn about on the pro genomic
testing and what this can do for them
the more likely they'll reach out and
consider having this test preemptively
for themself
I'm jawed our next question is have you
had any success with reimbursement or
expanded medication coverage from Betty
map testing
so all of our Medi map tests are panels
like I mentioned which means we test
several genes of several medications and
although health insurance companies
aren't currently reimbursing for these
tests some of them do allow their
members to use their flexible spending
accounts and healthcare savings account
towards this type of test one of the
best things I've actually heard recently
was we had a few patients who had this
test ordered by their ANOVA physician
and their many map results came back and
in the red category medication that they
were previously on basis they basically
said that it was not the best option for
them and in their dream category which
means based on their genes would be the
best option for them
unfortunately that medication was not
covered by their insurance so their
physician shared this result was their
insurance provider and after having that
information the insurance company
decided to cover the medication that was
previously not covered so although the
test itself isn't covered the results
are being being taken into account and
is changing people's life by covering
the right medication for them and you
know giving them a super cool pay so
that has been a great success
for us and we're hoping that this trend
continues and hopefully one day we'll be
able to get them to cover the entire
test
our physicians okay with patients
getting their genetic test results
directly as opposed to getting them from
their ordering physician yeah so as I
mentioned all the Medi map half our
purchase out-of-pocket so for us we
decided that the cost physical copy of
the results would always go to the
patient and we do not hold the results
for any amount of time to make sure that
the physician can review those results
initially some physicians had some
reservations about that
depending on whether or not they were
the ones that ordered it but I think as
they became more comfortable with the
content and the results um no one seems
to have an issue with that now in
Oakland physicians do have access to the
report as soon as it's available in the
IND electronic medical record and so
obviously would mail time that may be a
few days before the patient sees them
overall I think our physicians have been
very engaged and supportive and hasn't
really pushed back on having their
patient receive the result and it's
again important for us that patients are
empowered with this information and then
we do encourage everyone and it says it
on all of our reports and cover letters
that they must share their results with
all their providers whether they're you
know our providers are not a nova
provider than keep this copy in their
medical records
and it looks like we have time for one
more question for health care systems
that do not have their own
PGX programs what advice would you give
them to get started
very Christian but kind of touched on my
top lessons learned but one of the
things I would emphasize is or just make
sure that you have that executive
leadership support but then identify
some physician champions that can be
your spokespeople so yes although I said
you know consumers you know will embrace
this type of testing and physicians will
catch up it's it's also really important
to make sure that you have a team of
physicians that are on your side and for
us they have been critical in helping us
push this forward and not only that but
they're a big part of customizing the
programs and effectively integrating
them into our existing systems because
they are one of our most important and
users and creating a system that works
we're done is essential for our success
so engage your physician champions and
then start small
pick up program or a service line where
you have positions that are engaged and
they want to incorporate PGX testing
into their workflows so short small
identify a group and use it as a pilot
and after you've demonstrated success
take that and run with other locations
we did that with some of our outpatient
clinics and in parallel was one of our
inpatient programs which was the Medi
mad baby and I think wasn't for those
two smaller programs we would have never
gone to the point where we are today
I would like to once again think I'm
jazzed for her presentation I would also
like to thank Roberts for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing your July of 2018 we
will review an email from laberd's I
don't know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye